[Musique]
mieux d'essayer de voter plutôt au lieu
de plus tard parce que si ils marchèrent
aujourd'hui je peux rendre et de loin ou
dans quelques jours
j'espère que ça marche
oui ce qu'on sait les étudiants
universitaires ont intérêt à bien
s'informer avant d'aller voter
surtout s'ils sont originaires d'un
autre état comme tyler mane qui vient de
chicago en illinois qu'à cause de la
pandémie
beaucoup plusieurs étudiants n'ont pas
reçu leur carte d'université donc je
vais utiliser ma carte jeudi noir mais
j'ai eu une fiche d'identité d'une
université qui montre mon adresse à l'us
comme ça
elle a aussi apporté une preuve de
résidence elle croit avoir tout ce qu'il
faut pour voter par anticipation ce
matin il n'y a plus de cent mille jeunes
électeurs qui fréquentent les divers
campus universitaire où il conseille
enfin moi c'est beaucoup de monde quand
on pense que les élections se gagnent
par quelques dizaines de milliers de
voix ici certaines associations
étudiantes l'ont bien compris et se sont
associés à la commission électorale pour
inciter les jeunes à aller voter
à l'origine poursuite en cour fédérale
contre l'état du oui ce conseil qui
prétend que les restrictions à plat ce
brime les droits constitutionnels des
étudiants sa poursuite n'a aucune chance
d'être entendue avant le vote de mardi
ils ont accepté mon prof d'adressent et
ils n'ont pas accepté d'y lentilles avec
les photos donc il faut que je revienne
avec mon passeport possède deux
passeports
elle accepte de retourner le chercher à
sa place plusieurs étudiants auraient
déjà abandonné
[Musique]
au centre de cet état pivot il y à une
région pivot oshkosh dans l'autre homme
qui avait remporté un district par une
seule voix
pourtant des milliers d'électeurs
n'avaient pas pu voter par la poste
faute de bulletins étaient parmi ceux là
ce stratège républicain soutient qu'il
est très facile de voter ou ce qu'on
sait
vous êtes de retour de leur passeport
répond j'ai mon passeport et je verrai
si deuxième fois d'accord
il y as presque partout aux états unis
des lois qui limitent les droits et
augmente les contrats de certains
groupes d'électeurs
[Musique]
cette fois c'était très rapide
j'ai mis le bulletin du voter dans
l'europe est restée
c'est fait les risques d'affrontements
physiques entre partisans des deux cas
sont pris très au sérieux ici puisqu'on
sait comme dans plusieurs autres états
pivots il faudra probablement attendre
de 24 à 48 heures après le jour du vote
pour que tous les bulletins soient
contenus de confiance de ma vie a
raconté
j'espère
ce père gros coup mais
je pense pas je pense que personne
pour dire concrètement que ça va marcher
[Musique]